AI technology is advancing at an  alarming rate it's already being  utilized in the film industry for tasks  such as special effects and  post-production work as AI becomes more  sophisticated and widely adopted there  is a terrifying possibility that it  could take on more complex tasks and  decision making within the industry such  as writing scripts or directing movies  the Cutthroat and cost-sensitive nature  of the film industry could also Drive  the adoption of AI leading to an  uncertain future for human professionals  we should brace ourselves for the  possibility that AI could eventually  become a central player in the  production process of our beloved movies  the thought of this is really terrifying  don't believe me well that entire  paragraph was just written by AI so  we're basically already there